je veux consacrer les deux ans et demi
qui nous séparent de l'élection
présidentielle pour redonner une partie
de ce que j'ai reçu à ma famille
politique est en tout cas le faire avec
toute la conviction et l'engagement qui
est le mien
et ça ça veut dire qu'il faut parler à
tous les français de tous les sujets
vous mesurez bien de manière assez
objective les deux mondes totalement
étranger qu'il ya entre la promesse ici
à la l'élection d' emmanuel macron qui
celle de rassembler et la droite et la
gauche et donc l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et l'état aujourd'hui de
saccage de l'opinion dans dans notre
pays notre notre mouvement est au
travail il est plein d'enthousiasmé
plein d'espoir aussi nous sommes vu un
groupe et une formation un mouvement
politique d'opposition mais une
opposition responsable qui n'est pas là
simplement pour ajouter les tensions
étaient là pour faire la des
propositions concrètes en face à heml
macron dont l'arrogance dissimule tout
simplement l'impuissance nous devons
tenir
nous devons tenir sur nos convictions
sur notre ambition de reconstruire un
grand parti le parti de l'alternance
c'est dans les moments difficiles qu'on
voit les gens courageux et c'est
évidemment dans ce moment compliqué que
nous traversons tous ensemble que je
crois nous pouvons faire preuve au tour
de christian de la persévérance
nécessaires pour reconstruire une
proposition politique qui demain pourra
susciter l'adhésion des français jour
chaque sujet on a posé un constat
à partir du constat on tire une analyse
et ensuite on ouvre des axes deux axes
de réflexion je n'ai jamais vu un tel
travail de fond sur un temps aussi long
c'est en réalité la crise du manque de
résultats que nous vivons crois que nos
compatriotes avec la moins de discours
moins de bureaucratie et plus de
proximité sur la taxe d'habitation
il avait décidé de supprimer un impôt
qui vous appartient pas
[Musique]
nous avons pour ambition de démontrer
aux français que nous sommes bien le
parti du travail de la valeur du travail
de la récompense du travail et c'est
notre grande différence avec le
président l'a de vie comme avec des
extrêmes neil mac roman aux français
pour sauver le régime des retraites
il faut dire la vérité aux français je
pense que jamais on atteint un tel
niveau sur le désarmement soit régaliens
dont on regarde les chiffres ils sont
hallucinants jeu dont souffre le plus
aujourd'hui
les forces de l'ordre ces espèces de
manque de considération qu'ils ont à à
cause des moyens matériels très dégradé
nous sommes le parti de la laïcité quand
on voit l'aveuglément et la naïveté du
président de la république sur le sujet
nous sommes et nous osons dire que
l'islam politique est notre adversaire
nous avons cette lourde responsabilité
d'être les moteurs d'une europe qui soit
à la fois stratège et qui s'affirme
durablement et républicains au travers
de six forums pour s'intéresser
particulièrement à l'agriculture
l'engagement qui est le nôtre qui est
celui des républicains s'est d'ailleurs
de porter la voix des agriculteurs et de
les accompagner pour répondre à ses
ambitions face à nous on a une
problématique entière c'est la confiance
entre le consommateur ce qui va dans son
assiette et le producteur c'est un
français sur trois qui est concerné
c'est 11 millions de personnes porteuses
d'un handicap
nous renouons avec l'histoire de cette
grande maison
un celle des républicains celle de la
droite républicaine depuis de longues
décennies protéger les femmes c'est agir
au niveau national mais c'est aussi agir
au niveau local le thème des femmes et
de l'audace qui est je crois nécessaire
utile à la construction des chefs de
gouvernement de l'otan sur son nuage
dense est lui dirigé le pays douceur
cette crise a montré une chose sans
l'appui des cônes il n'y aurait pas le
plus possible contre la propagation dans
ce sens les maires sont les acteurs de
territoire cette crise ne pourrait pas
être surmontés
c'est la jeunesse ya la nécessité de
construire un nouveau pont jeunes et on
doit le construire en reflet de ce
qu'est notre société chaque enfant doit
pouvoir mieux vivre que ses parents
grâce à son travail grâce à ses études
grâce à sa volonté
[Musique]
quel autre parti politique est capable
aujourd'hui de rassembler plus de 1000
jeunes pendant deux jours pour parler
politique pour travailler parler de
l'avenir
[Musique]
ce que l'on peut dire ce soir c'est que
nous renouer avec la victoire c'est une
grande et belle victoire pour les
républicains
nous avons gagné les municipales c'est à
dire que sur le les élections
territoriales les français en fait
confiance au candidat de droite et
notamment candidats les républicains et
les élections sénatoriales c'est le
prolongement et c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de nous préparer aux autres
échéances territoriales au départemental
et aux régionales plus que jamais nous
avons besoin de vous nous avons besoin
que vous nous rejoignez nous avons
besoin de vous pour préparer la france
de demain ce projet alternatif à
l'actuelle équipe gouvernementale
et ça ça se fera dans un esprit de
rassemblement autour des républicains
venez avec nous pour bâtir ce beau
projet
[Musique]